there is no greater scourge
facing america from within the president
takes the opioid crisis
very seriously
the kid got snagged at the border the
courier
took a year of undercover work to get
this far amy is dangerous to press a big
sale now
but what choice do we have
our product will be the first truly
non-addictive painkiller
what the hell is going on all the
addiction centers are lighting up and
then by day 10
they're dead
i'm looking for my son were you aware of
any issues
with your son like what
based on your results you want
northlight to pull their billion-dollar
drug
that can cost you a hell of a lot more
than your teaching job
you've got to have a plan a plan but
tell them the truth
careful should this kid get an itch to
name names
[Music]
would be unpleasant for everyone
they're gonna come after you but what
you're doing now
may be the most important thing you ever
do
you had my son run drugs for you
this is the biggest public health crisis
since tobacco
it's not our responsibility and who's is
it
you cannot walk into that by alone we
can't quit
we can't stop
what do you think we're here to do to
make a difference
we can touch you anywhere in the world
we're running out of time
last chance
you